[Música]
la justicia peruana evaluó el pedido de
la Fiscalía de ordenar detención
preliminar por flagrancia contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo entre tanto
la presidenta Dina boluarte descartó
adelantar las elecciones y confirmó que
Perú realizará la Cumbre de la alianza
del Pacífico Tenemos reporte desde la
Ciudad de Lima
El Congreso de Estados Unidos aprobó un
proyecto de ley que busca blindar a
nivel Federal el matrimonio igualitario
de esta manera se busca proteger un
derecho y también evitar un escenario
como el que ya tuvo lugar con la
revocatoria de la ley que permitía la
interrupción del embarazo
la estrella del baloncesto
estadounidense Britney greiner va en
camino hacia los Estados Unidos luego de
que Rusia aceptara liberarla a cambio de
la liberación del Traficante de armas
ruso Víctor Wood hay reacciones mixtas
por el contexto de la guerra en Ucrania
y también porque el liberado ruso se
considera el mayor Traficante de armas
de la historia
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en Perú
para actualizar algunos de los hechos
más recientes que han tenido lugar en
este país en torno a la destitución del
presidente olla expresidente Pedro
Castillo quien permanece bajo custodia
de las autoridades peruanas para ello
vamos entonces en directo hasta la
Ciudad de Lima ya se encuentra mi
compañero Francisco Zacarías desde la
capital peruana con más detalles
Francisco Muy buenas tardes y en qué
fundamenta la justicia peruana ese
pedido de la Fiscalía de detención
preliminar de 7 días contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo
Santiago Muy buenas tardes el juez Juan
Carlos cheque validó la posición de la
fiscalía que señalaba que para tener
éxito el delito de rebelión no era
necesario que esté consumado Qué
aconteció es que la fiscalía venía
señalando que Pedro Castillo hizo una
violación flagrante de la
constitucionalidad y el orden
democrático y al disolver el parlamento
y convocar a las fuerzas armadas para
que respalden su medida extrema esto
constituía el delito grave de lo que se
conoce se está hablando en estos
momentos de Conspiración y también de
rebelión Esto fue rebatido por la
defensa de Pedro Castillo que señalaba
que no puede existir el delito de
rebelión ni tampoco de Conspiración
porque para que eso se constituya se
requiere el alzamiento en armas Pedro
Castillo no se alzó de armas y tampoco
vio al parlamento Pues bien el juez Juan
Carlos Cheli luego de oír las ponencias
terminó por apoyar la posición de la
fiscalía es así que Pedro Castillo va a
tener que
tener una detención preliminar por siete
días en la prisión de barbadío donde es
compañero de celda del expresidente
Alberto fujimori apenas comienza
entonces este proceso judicial contra la
expresidente Castillo Francisco también
hace pocos minutos o hace unas cuantas
horas la presidenta Dina boluarte en
unas declaraciones dijo que por ahora
descarta la posibilidad de convocar a
elecciones anticipadas qué más dijo la
mandataria
bueno Dina boluarte lo que quiere la
presidenta nueva de Perú es que haya un
consenso y ahorita más se enfoca en que
haya la continuidad democrática del
periodo
2021-2026 ella está enfatizando
esfuerzos para atender puentes con los
diversos grupos del país y también
generar confianza y armar un nuevo
gabinete de gobierno vamos a escuchar lo
que habló Dina boluarte
Yo sé que hay algunas voces que indican
adelanto de elecciones Y eso
democráticamente es respetable creo que
la Asunción de la presidencia en esta
oportunidad es un poco reorientar lo que
hay que hacer con el país más adelante
en coordinación con todas las
organizaciones
estaremos viendo alternativas de mejor
reorientar los destinos del país
Francisco para terminar este esta
actualización de lo más reciente que ha
ocurrido allá en Perú muchas personas se
siguen preguntando qué sigue entonces
para el expresidente Castillo en materia
jurídica que hay por delante para Pedro
Castillo
Bueno lo que sucede es que ahorita la
defensa de Pedro Castillo se está
reagrupando hay que tener en cuenta que
no solamente renunciaron sus ministros
de estado sino también sus abogados el
anterior Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres
ahora lo está defendiendo y están
tratando de ver cómo interponen recursos
de Amparo y algunas acciones en la
justicia peruana entre ellos en el
tribunal constitucional y en el frente
externo también van a recurrir a la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
porque ellos consideran que se han
vulnerado los derechos del expresidente
Pedro Castillo entonces va a haber una
actividad legal tanto de parte de la
fiscalía como de parte de la defensa de
Pedro castillo y sobre todo en estos
momentos la defensa de Pedro Castillo va
a tratar de ver cómo liberarlo Esa es la
situación a la cual vamos a estar
atentos en francés veinticuatro por
supuesto muy atentos Francisco
Muchísimas gracias por este completo
reporte desde la Ciudad de Lima la
capital Perú
la capital del Perú vamos a seguir
hablando de este país porque como lo
decíamos luego la destitución de Pedro
Castillo Dina boluarte asumió como la
primera presidenta de Perú siguiendo la
cadena de sucesión del cargo se espera
que entonces esté al mando de este país
hasta el 2026 Aunque su permanencia va a
depender como lo decíamos de la relación
que pueda tener con el parlamento o con
la oposición de derecha veamos de quién
se trata
de la República luego de un tsunami
político en Perú Dina ercilia boluarte
zegarra se convirtió en la primera mujer
en la historia de ese país en juramentar
como presidenta luego de la destitución
de Pedro castillo proveniente del
departamento de Apurímac la política de
60 años aseguró que defenderá la
soberanía nacional y que cumplirá con la
Constitución durante su primer discurso
ante el congreso legislativo
me comprometo ante el país a luchar
porque los
los excluidos los ajenos tengan la
oportunidad y el acceso que
históricamente se les ha negado que vive
el Perú Muchas gracias
la nueva mandataria de Perú es abogada
de profesión tiene una larga carrera
política y hasta este 7 de diciembre se
desempeñó como vicepresidenta y titular
del Ministerio de desarrollo e inclusión
social Pero también estuvo en la mira de
la oposición luego de ser investigada
por tráfico de influencias y corrupción
Aunque su caso fue archivado esta misma
semana por ahora se espera que buluarte
este al mando hasta el 28 de julio de
2026 fin del actual mandato sin embargo
su permanencia dependerá de su relación
con el parlamento y la posición liderada
por la derecha de keiko fujimori quien
dio la bienvenida a la nueva presidenta
saludo la juramentación de Dina boluarte
como primera presidenta del Perú deseo
que su gestión se cumpla en respeto a la
institucionalidad democrática separación
de poderes y por el desarrollo de
nuestro país para ello podrá contar con
el apoyo y respaldo de fuerza popular
durante su ceremonia de juramentación
boluarte pidió un plazo para lograr una
tregua entre los diferentes actores
políticos y llamó a que se abran los
canales de diálogo para acabar de una
vez por todas con la crisis política de
Perú
dejamos Perú nos vamos ahora hasta
Estados Unidos porque el congreso de ese
país aprobó un proyecto de ley que busca
blindar a nivel Federal el matrimonio
igualitario el texto además protege de
la discriminación en caso de que el
tribunal supremo decidiera revocar este
derecho ya adquirido como ya lo hizo con
el derecho a la interrupción del
embarazo la cámara de representantes de
mayoría demócrata validó este proyecto
con 258 votos a favor y 169 en contra
después de que el senado se hubiera
pronunciado en la misma línea el pasado
29 de noviembre con 61 votos positivos y
36 negativos ahora se espera solamente
que el presidente Joe biden en la casa
blanca lo ratifique para que pueda
entrar en vigor a nivel Federal la
legislación promueve que el Gobierno
Federal reconozca el matrimonio
igualitario el matrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo si es legal en los
estados donde que se casaron el mismo
principio se aplica a las bodas
interraciales
hoy defendemos los valores que la gran
mayoría de los estadounidenses aprecian
una creencia querida una creencia en la
dignidad la belleza y la divinidad La
chispa de la divinidad en cada persona
un respeto permanente por el amor tan
poderoso que une a dos personas a su
equipo
y en otros temas la dos veces en
medallista de oro del baloncesto Britney
grainer que había sido condenada nueve
años de prisión en Rusia fue
intercambiada por Víctor Wood el llamado
mercader de las armas un extraficante de
armas considerado el mayor de la
historia hay polémica en torno a este
tema y polémica en torno a esa decisión
que ha tomado el gobierno de Washington
tomando en medio pues la guerra en
Ucrania y porque el intercambio de la
deportista se realizó por un de
reconocidos delincuente veamos más
detalles en el siguiente informe
es libre así lo confirmó el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden escoltado por
la esposa de su vicepresidenta y el
secretario de estado hace un momento
junto a su esposa sherell en la oficina
oval hablé con Britney wriner está a
salvo está en un avión está camino a
casa
grainer campeona olímpica de baloncesto
fue detenida en Rusia el pasado mes de
febrero por tener aceite de Cannabis en
su equipaje al entrar a ese territorio
en agosto fue condenada a nueve años de
cárcel por Contrabando y posesión de
drogas Estados Unidos ahora enfoca sus
esfuerzos en la liberación de Paul
Williams un exmarin acusado de espionaje
también arrestado en la nación
euroasiática el pasado 2018 después de
meses de detención injusta en Rusia
Britney binner está de camino a casa con
su esposa cherrell y otros de sus seres
queridos nos estaremos en nuestros
esfuerzos hasta que Paul William también
regrese con su familia Britney fue
intercambiada por quien era considerado
los hombres más buscados del mundo el
ciudadano ruso Víctor void un Traficante
de armas conocido como el mercader de la
muerte
y seguimos profundizando en este tema
porque también hay controversia respecto
al intercambio entre Rusia y Estados
Unidos porque hay otros ciudadanos
estadounidenses condenados por las
autoridades de Moscú entre ellos Paul
William antiguo integrante de Infantería
de la Marina de Estados Unidos quien se
mostró completamente decepcionado
asegurando que la Casa Blanca no ha
hecho lo suficiente por su Liberación el
hombre está condenado a 16 años de
prisión por cargos de espionaje que
siempre ha negado la reacción se produce
a poco de que se cumplan ya cuatro años
de su arresto en tierras rusas
pasamos a otros temas de la actualidad
en Ucrania Las bajas temperaturas y
también las condiciones que trae el
invierno boreal ha dificultado las
operaciones que compromete la guerra en
el terreno nuestra aviada especial a
Ucrania Catalina Gómez Ángel nos explica
por qué nos da más información en su
reporte
esta lluvia
enzimáticas que marca Las mayores
dificultades ahora que llega el invierno
estamos en la ciudad de Nitro a cuatro
horas del frente del donbas de donde
regresamos anoche y allí nos contaban
quienes pelean en ese frente que en este
momento cuando regresa el agua y se
descongela la nieve que ha caído en los
últimos días hace imposible la vida en
esas trincheras que cada vez son más
activas especialmente en la ciudad de
backmud donde la pelea se intensifica
cada día más pero también nos cuentan
que trae sus ventajas porque esta Niebla
hace casi imposible el vuelo de los
drones que son fundamentales en esta
guerra que comenzó el 24 de febrero
solamente anoche los rusos volvían a
lanzar 14 drones de fabricación
iranídrones kami casi que fueron
interceptados por la defensas ucranianas
pero allí en el frente nos cuentan que
hay dos tipos de drones que hacen la
vida tanto para unos como para otros el
primero es el dron orlanum una un dron
Ruso que vuela bastante alto y que tiene
una cámara con bastante precisión que
ayuda a dar mensajes y a precisar la
artillería lo que hace que los rusos
están atacando con mayor precisión en
especialmente en la posición de bacmut
pero los ucranianos también usan sus
drones especialmente drones comerciales
los típicos que se consiguen en
cualquier tienda que ellos utilizan para
también controlar las posiciones
enemigas y estos soldados especialmente
por los voluntarios ucranianos estamos
en una estación de gasolina por ejemplo
donde cada litro que se consume da una
un grigna o la moneda de ucraniana para
comprar esos drones que ayudan a los
soldados en el frente de batalla
Catalina Gómez Ángel reportando desde
Ucrania en otros temas Arabia Saudita y
China firmaron acuerdos estratégicos
integrales con el fin de profundizar Los
lazos entre estos dos países esto se dio
durante la visita de estado que Está
realizando el presidente chino en la que
calificó a react como un socio muy
importante más allá de occidente para el
desarrollo la paz y la estabilidad
mundial los líderes de ambos países
manifestaron su voluntad también de
aumentar el comercio de petróleo también
implementar proyectos energéticos y
promover la inversión en ambos países
con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias aquí en France 24 siga con
nosotros buenas tardes
[Música]